a number of fields in global health
there are areas in which having new
knowledge new methods new techniques
would be of invaluable help and examples
would be in water and sanitation having
better ways technical solutions to
creating potable water in places that
don't have it and don't have enough of
it now some new vaccines obviously the
HIV vaccine is of vital importance a
functional and effective malaria vaccine
is of great importance improved
therapeutic tools and diagnostic tools
for tuberculosis but for other global
problems such as tobacco nutrition
technical solutions are less relevant to
applying what we all already know many
of these issues the some of which we
would call lifestyle issues issues
really to what we eat or drink habits we
have such as smoking or not smoking
physical activity are becoming
increasingly common every part of the
world they were obviously some of these
issues are of greater concern in some
places than others but the overall trend
is that we're all going to share common
concerns so even in the last few years
one sees increasing rates of obesity
tobacco use in places where this wasn't
an issue before and so yes there are
places where we can show great progress
such as tobacco control and Western
Europe Australia the United States
Canada but it remains a huge problem in
other parts of the world for things such
as diet some countries haven't yet
experienced the over nutrition problems
that we have in you in the US and and
the West but will and we haven't come to
grips with solving our own problems in
that area so increasingly this
opportunity to share information
knowledge what we can do about these
problems but these problems are tough
ones
I think it depends on what countries
you're in because of the it shifts by
place to place right now in the u.s.
probably the major problem is obesity
epidemic of obesity will have the most
impact on our health for the next 50
years plus in many parts of the world
tobacco use is the most significant
epidemic going on will have the biggest
impact in health and in some parts of
the world it's a combination of malaria
HIV AIDS and TB so depending on where
you travel to which continent which part
of it various some are infectious
diseases and some are behavioral risk
factors but contribute to significant
health problems we've had many success
stories few of them have made it to the
headlines yet tends not to make such
good news it makes good news it is good
news but it doesn't make good sales of
the news and I think over the 20th
century we've had a series of major
health advances particularly in the US
and I'll mention that for the u.s. such
as a fifty percent reduction in deaths
from heart disease a mark reduction in
people who smoke cigarettes a marked
reduction in automobile collision
fatalities based on increased improved
training and education safety factors in
cars and roads etc markedly improved
dentition and oral health from
fluoridation of drinking water and
attention to proper oral hygiene marked
improvement in child health and maternal
health largely at the beginning of the
20th century but area after area in
which we have made considerable advances
and in which the health of our
population today looks very different
than it would have looked 50 years ago
or 100 years ago in the developing world
we've seen advances and improvement
since
places even as we have seen setbacks and
others and if you look over all at the
health and well-being of some of our big
biggest populations such as China or
India Bangladesh one can see some real
improvements in nutrition and other risk
factors in a decline in the infectious
diseases and improvements in
immunizations which have led to a marked
improvement in health South America as
well in country after country has made
mark improvements in health over the
last 50 years the education of girls and
young women is extraordinarily important
in health because in almost every
society in the world health decisions
and families are made by the women in
that family and they recognize the
importance of various factors related to
health they tend to be responsible for
what goes on in the home and for all
elements related to nutrition water
quality a range of other things but also
just when someone is ill they're the
carers and the the people who pay the
most attention so there's no issue that
and it's proven over and over again that
women's education correlates well with
improvement in health well I think an
example of an organization that attends
to this and has it high on their
priority list is care the
non-governmental organization that
focuses on development and health based
in Atlanta and they have as one of their
top priorities girls and women's
education development well-being health
and recognized this not just targeting
just the girls but the fact that the
impact they'll have on everyone else
around them is for the good of all and
countries that in the past have been
resistant to this are much better at it
I've spent a lot of time over my career
working in Bangladesh and when I go back
for a visit now and my colleagues there
say to me what's the most impressive
difference you see here when you come
back
after having first worked here 35 37
years ago and the answer I give them
always amazes them because they expect
me to sell the big new buildings in the
new airport and lots more cars and the
answer i always give is the wonderful
sight of girls and young women girls who
are adolescents and late adolescents in
school uniforms walking to school in the
mornings that's the most heartening
sight I see in that country the obesity
epidemic is one that's taken us a couple
of decades or longer to get to it's
multifactorial so there are lots of
issues involved in what led to it and
similarly it's going to take us a number
of years maybe decades to get out of
this and the perfect storm of factors
that have led to obesity include what we
how much we eat when we where we eat and
then all the same questions for physical
activity so the development of
overweight or obesity is a function of
how many calories we take in and how
many we burn and we're clearly in an
imbalance as a society and it's not
necessarily an individual's fault it's
the way we structured life in modern day
not just the US and the West and in many
other countries to boot so in the past
where we might have gotten physical
activity and burning calories from
walking to our job and walking home
walking to a trolley that took us
somewhere into his home walking to
school and walking back there doing
household chores doing yard work and
doing jobs that involve a lot of
physical activity those opportunities
are largely lost there are very few jobs
and we would think of a few but very few
jobs that involve huge caloric
expenditures and most of us are a desk
or in offices or when we move around
it's not very far so we're not burning
this
so we try to balance that by getting
more exercise you know purposeful
physical activity of large muscle groups
but it's hard to do that for everybody
it's expensive for some people it
doesn't come naturally and so that's
tough on the other side of the equation
is there was a time recently in American
life where every place you went didn't
offer you food it's hard to imagine now
but there was a time when gas stations
just sold gas they might have provided
air for your tires and oil and they
might have fixed your car and they might
have given you dishes as in our glasses
as an incentive to come back but they
didn't offer a full service junk food
store as part of their Emporium and
indeed people go there and it's not just
gas stations it's it's throughout life
they're just vending machines and places
around where you can if you are tempted
to eat all day long and that's often
true in schools it's true in the
workplace etc so we've created an
environment where we're tempted all the
time with foods that are high in fat and
salt and caloric content we tend to
snack between meals and portion sizes
creeped up as well and this well
documented for everything from muffins
cookies portions through at restaurants
that you serve the size of a hamburger
all these things have increased markedly
in size and we've been taught for a long
time to eat everything on our plate and
we do and more so it's not surprising
that we have a problem but it is going
to be a challenge to address it it's a
significant factor for ill health and we
really need to whether it's its
contribution of diabetes heart disease
stroke high blood pressure